so gus bradley not ken wisenhutt will be
the defensive coordinator in
las vegas they had the mike zimmer
paul gunther approach so uh oh here we
are
seattle scheme chris do they have the
players to pull off the seattle scheme
well
no they have a lot of that's that's
where the raiders got to spend their
whole offseason on the defensive side of
the ball
they got to improve their defensive line
they still got a little work in their
secondary there i mean
that's really a big issue for them as as
a team
but gus bradley uh he he's a phenomenal
coach and yes you've heard me i've had
my issues with that seattle scheme i do
think it's a little too predictable at
times
but i'll say this mike one thing i saw
throughout the year this year
the seattle scheme people realized it
they realized it this year
they did seattle specifically the
seattle seahawks
played more variety of defenses than
i've ever seen them play in the pete
carroll era
so they've realized it too and that goes
for you know some of the other defensive
schemes like that out there as well and
of course gus bradley he's really the
inventor of this defensive scheme
i mean this scheme and what he did
started in tampa
with john gruden with monty kiffin
pete carroll used to come down there as
the usc head coach
and visit us in the spring to get a few
ideas for his own defense
and then you know pete got the job at
seattle and of course called the people
he knows and he knew a lot of people in
tampa
and gus ended his way up there but gus
you know
extremely smart knows john gruden got a
great way
about him energy everything like that
and their defense has stunk through the
grudenera so i think this will really
work for them and help them out but it's
they got to help the players on the
field too they need more players on the
field is what i'm saying
well and that's the key and we've seen
how teams like the panthers last year
devoted their entire draft to the
defensive side of the ball and maybe
that's just what the raiders need to do
when you have a great offensive head
coach yeah and you've got the pieces you
need on that side of the ball
you can't neglect the defense and and
that's one of the things that was
pointed out to me after paul gunther was
fired
all of the resources devoted in 2020
to the offensive side of the ball free
agency money yep
and draft picks what do you expect your
defense to be if you're not going to
make the appropriate investment in the
players
on that side of the ball it's it's going
to suffer and now they've got
they've got to do what they can because
that's what's holding them back
especially
this idea that the only way to beat the
chiefs is to outscore them there's some
merit to that
but you still have to have a defense
against other teams
you can't you can't just lay down
against the rest of the teams on your
schedule yeah just because your attitude
toward
kansas city is we're never going to hold
them under 30 so let's focus on scoring
40. well
and you know kansas city's defense is no
cupcake you're not just guaranteed to
just you know
dominate them for 30 or 40 either so you
better have some sort of a defense right
to where maybe you can beat
you know kansas city 27 24 something
along those lines
um but but definitely yeah you know
it can't just be all about the offense
and shooting it out and i think this is
a marriage that makes a lot of sense
uh but the big thing will be especially
defense alignment that's where the
raiders have really whiffed
you know they have nobody on that side
of the line of scrimmage on that
defensive front four
that you worry about in the slightest
bit max crosby's really good
but he's not really good to where you go
oh we gotta double him or chip the back
on him or do anything like that
they don't have one difference maker or
game plan changer
on that front and you know to what you
were saying that's what they got to do
they got to invest heavily on that next
this is this offseason
you know we've talked about the andy
reed coaching tree and how it's kicked
out doug peterson matt and aggie and
we're waiting for eric b enemy to get
his chance pete carroll had that same
thing going in the heyday of the
seahawks
it was gus bradley then it was dan quinn
right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports